un peu plus d'une heure pour répondre
aux questions des parlementaires
ce mardi le ministre de la santé a
défendu la stratégie vaccinale du
gouvernement dès les premières minutes
olivier vers en a donné le ton nous ne
naviguons pas à vue une stratégie a été
défini par la haute autorité de santé
qui est je le rappelle une autorité
indépendante et une logistique établis
avec des cabinets de conseil privé un
sujet sur lequel le ministre de la santé
était particulièrement attendue donc on
a on a de très solides
l'entreprise française qui fonctionne
très bien qu'ils sont capables de
fournir tous les services et ce serait
ce pardon pour le je mets des guillemets
ce serait salle parce que ce serait
privé mais attendez c'est pas du tout du
tout du tout ma vision de la france de
l'esprit d'entreprendre et de notre
capacité de nous appuyer sur toutes les
compétences réponse insatisfaisante pour
le député la france insoumises du nord
adrien cas tenace pourquoi l'état
s'affaiblit à ce point en recourant
systématiquement à des prestataires
privés pour des missions qui sont des
missions régaliennes de l'état
je pense notamment à au contrat passé
avec mc kinsey dont on nous dit qu'un
apport deux millions d'euros par mois
n'at-on pas des logisticiens des gens
capables de planifier au sein de
l'appareil d'état bref il ya beaucoup de
questions toute sa stratégie vaccinale
face à un démarrage de la vaccination au
compte-gouttes la transparence des
chiffres a elle aussi été évoquée j'ai
demandé à ce que tous les jours à 19h30
au plus tard soit publié les données
dont nous disposons c'est à dire le
nombre de vaccins réalisé par région le
pourcentage de population protégée
le nombre de doses dont disposent les
régions et ainsi le pourcentage de doses
qui ont été consommées dans chaque
région
l'accès aux vaccins notamment en milieu
rural était aussi au coeur de l'audition
olivier verrons a écarté la réquisition
des stades leur préférant une politique
de proximité n'est pas fait le choix de
ces gros vaccinodromes à l'échelle
régionale qui aurait impliqué pour des
personnes âgées de 85 ans en plein hiver
de faire 150 km et des heures de queue à
l'extérieur d'un gymnase je revendique
cela et je crois que c'est très bien
accepté par les élus
enfin les députés ont mis sur la table
la question de la mobilisation des
personnalités publiques
inciter les français à se faire vacciner
a urgence olivier ferrand répond
patience pour moi l'exemplarité vu ce
que j'ai à dire c'est d'attendre son
tour c'est d'attendre son tour
je suis médecin soignant ministre de la
santé
je suis âgée de moins de 50 ans je ne
fais pas vacciner
olivier verrons qui a aussi rappelé
l'objectif du gouvernement
un million de personnes vaccinées à la
fin du mois de février
pour l'heure près de 140 mille personnes
ont été vaccinées depuis le début de la
campagne le 27 décembre dernier
c'est environ cinq fois moins que
l'allemagne ou l'italie ont eux aussi
fortement impacté par l'épidémie